circuit의 크기는
수행해야 하는 기본 연산의 수에 해당해요.
그 연산들을 순차적으로 수행한다면
크기가 얼마나 걸리는지 알려주니까
circuit 크기를 순차적 실행 시간으로 생각할 수 있어요.
이것이 이 강의에서 계산 비용을
측정하는 방법이 될 거예요.
하지만 circuit을 실행하는 데 필요한 시간으로
볼 수 있는 또 다른 속성이 있는데,
그건 circuit의 깊이예요.
정확하게 말하면, 깊이는 입력 와이어에서
출력 와이어까지의 경로에서 만나는 gate의 최대 수예요.
이건 circuit을 만드는 데 필요한 gate 층의 수와 동일한데,
층이란 공통 와이어가 없어서
동시에 수행할 수 있는
gate 묶음을 말해요.
예를 들어, 아까의 circuit은
깊이가 4이고, 다이어그램에서 직접 4개의 층을 볼 수 있어요.
FANOUT gate들은 동시에
수행할 수 있고, NOT gate들도
동시에 수행할 수 있고, AND gate들도
마찬가지로 동시에 수행할 수 있어요.
그래서 circuit 깊이를 병렬 실행 시간으로 생각할 수 있어요.
circuit 깊이는 확실히 흥미롭고 중요한 개념이고, 일부 계산에 필요한
깊이를 줄이는 데 사용할 수 있는
매우 정교한 기법들이 있어요. 때로는 실제로 상당히 극적으로요. 하지만 이건 고급 주제이고
이 시리즈에서 이에 대해 더 많이 이야기하진 않을 거예요.
다시 한번 말하면, 계산 비용을
circuit 크기, 다시 말해
계산을 수행하는 데 필요한 기본 연산의 수로 측정할 거예요.
강의 시작 부분에서 정수 인수분해 문제에 대해 이야기했고,
이 문제를 풀기 위한 알고리즘에 필요한 시간이
입력 길이가 늘어나면 증가할 수 있다는 걸 봤어요.
이것이 보통 우리가 초점을 맞추는 문제예요.
알고리즘을 분석할 때요.
즉, 입력이 점점 커질수록 알고리즘 실행 비용이 어떻게 변하는지에 관심이 있어요.
물론, 이런 확장성만이 중요한 건 아니에요.
예를 들어, 단순히 RSA1024의 인수를 찾는 것에만
관심이 있을 수도 있어요. 그게 전부요.
그런 경우에는 아무것도 커지지 않는
단일 문제 인스턴스에 대해 이야기하는 거예요.
하지만 알고리즘에 대해 생각할 때, 비용이
어떻게 변하는지가 매우 중요하고 알고리즘에 대해
많은 것을 알려줘요.
이 관점은 알고리즘이
근본적이라는 아이디어와 일치해요. 전에 이야기했듯이
시간이 지나고 기술이 발전하면, 점점 더 큰
입력에 대해 적용될 거예요.
하지만 계산 문제의 입력은
크기가 커질 수 있지만 circuit은 커지지 않는다는 점을 주목하세요.
각 circuit은 고정된 크기를 가지고 있어요.
그래서 circuit을 사용해서 알고리즘을 설명하려면
실제로 circuit의 패밀리가 필요해요.
circuit의 패밀리란 입력을 수용할 수 있도록
점점 커지는 circuit 모음을 말해요.
입력이 점점 커지니까요. 예를 들어, 정수 인수분해 문제에 대한
고전 결정론적 알고리즘을 생각해 볼게요.
시행 나눗셈에 기반한 것일 수 있지만, 이 예시에서
구체적인 방법은 별로 중요하지 않아요.
이 예시의 목적상요.
원칙적으로 이런 알고리즘을 Boolean circuit의 패밀리로 설명할 수 있는데,
인수분해하려는 숫자의
이진 표현이 N비트라면, 패밀리에서 circuit CN을 가져와서
인수분해하려는 숫자를
그 circuit의 입력 비트에 넣으면 돼요.
때로는 이 circuit들을 다른 방식으로 매개변수화할 수 있어서,
N번째 circuit이 항상 N개의 입력 비트를 가지는 건 아닐 수 있지만
꽤 전형적인 방법이에요. 자연스럽게
입력 길이가 길어지면 이 패밀리의 circuit이 더 커질 거라고 예상하는데
이건 예를 들어 4비트 숫자를
인수분해하는 것이 1,024비트 숫자를 인수분해하는 것보다 훨씬 쉽다는 사실을 반영해요.
그래서, 이를 염두에 두면, 이런 알고리즘의 비용을
각 가능한 입력 길이에 대해 얼마나 많은 기본 연산이
필요한지 알려주는 함수로 측정해요. 이건 고전과 양자 알고리즘 모두에 적용할 수 있어요.
예로, 인수분해나
GCD 계산보다 확실히 훨씬 간단한 정수 덧셈 문제를 생각해 볼게요.
정수 덧셈이요.
간단하게, N과 M이 모두 비음수 정수이고
같은 길이의 이진 문자열로 표현된다고 가정할게요.
같은 길이의요.
이 두 숫자를 더하는 Boolean circuit을 어떻게 만들 수 있을까요?
표준 덧셈 알고리즘부터 시작해 볼게요. 이건 우리 모두 연필과 종이로 숫자를 더하는 방법으로
배운 것의 2진법 버전이에요. 가장 덜 중요한
비트부터 시작해서
더하면 결과의 가장 덜 중요한 비트와 함께
다음 자리에서 고려해야 할 올림 비트가 나와요.
비트를 따라 계속 진행하면서 출력 비트와
올림 비트를 생성해요.
끝에 도달할 때까지요.